I am super erigor joy I have the
difficult job of chairing this panel and
I want to thank Jonathan first for
asking me to do this most of you don't
know me I am a research affiliate at MIT
x' science technology and society
program I've been here about 10 years
but my most of my professional career I
was an engineer in defense industry
working on high-power lasers for Star
Wars and and I finally left that
profession being totally disgusted well
you haven't heard the punchline yet
I went to Congress as a science fellow
I think Alan was a science fellow also
in in Congress not the same time and
then I went to work for the Government
Accountability Office determined to
bring accountability to the Pentagon and
I ended up a becoming a whistleblower
because we had I had the lead job in
investigating a sensor failure in the
missile defense system interceptor and
and we found that the sense of didn't
work and that data was lost and so on
and so forth and it is about Boeing so I
tried to convince the watchdog agency of
Congress to publish my report detailing
the problems with the sensor and they
wouldn't so I blew the whistle and
eventually had to lose my job and I got
refuge at MIT about ten years ago so I'm
very happy that I'm able to do what I
want to do to most and it has something
to do with missile defense and that is
one of the most destabilizing factors in
the nuclear conflict and we're going to
talk about that later on
so we have today four speakers in our
panel on destabilizing factors three are
physicists one is a non physicist and we
start off with physicist Lisbeth Garland
who I know for a long time actually I
didn't meet but saw Lisbeth on
television during the Star Wars debate
debate this is back in 1984 I think and
and she's now of course very big shot
she's a single scientist and co-director
of the global security program at the
Union of Concerned Scientists who does
very very good work and Elizabeth
testified many times before the Congress
so I'm very happy to have Lizbeth as our
first speaker and I will introduce the
others as their turn constant thank you
great thank you thanks for coming today
it's great to see so many of you so I'm
going to talk about how nuclear weapons
might be used we already heard about the
consequences of their use how might this
actually happened but it talked about
the dangers of hair-trigger alert both
the United States and Russia keep
hundreds of land-based missile missiles
nuclear-armed missiles on alert so they
can be launched in a matter of minutes
and they do this because that way they
could not be destroyed by an incoming
attack the US has 450 missiles with a
single warhead in silos they look just
like this and there are four each ten of
these missiles there's an underground
bunker that is staffed 24/7 by two
people whose job it is to launch these
missiles if they are told to do so and
so the idea is if there is a launch of a
missile the US would detect it first
with satellite based infrared sensors
that detect the hot team of the missile
as it is launched and then by radars we
have radars around the world that would
also detect these incoming missiles and
then the clock starts ticking takes
about 30 minutes for a missile to travel
between Russia in the United States or
United States and Russia less time than
that if the missile is launched from a
submarine which could be much closer so
at most you have 30 minutes and it takes
several minutes for these satellite base
sensors
the radars to figure out what's going on
and then it takes several minutes for
the military to decide whether or not
this is a serious enough event if there
is an alert that it merits going up to
the president and for that reason there
is a person who follows the president
around carrying a black suitcase called
the nuclear football and this contains
communication equipment and a book with
basically by targeting plans so if the
alert goes up to this point the
president has about 10 minutes to make a
decision about whether or not to launch
its silo based nuclear weapons in
response to warning of an incoming
attack 10 minutes is not a long time so
there are risks associated with this
posture one there could be because these
missiles are poised to be launched it
increases the risk that the launch could
be by accident it increases the risk of
an unauthorized launch it makes it
easier for people to gain control of
these weapons and perhaps most important
it creates the risk of a deliberate
launch but in response to a false
warning and this is not just a
theoretical problem there have been
numerous close calls in the past I'm
going to talk just about three of them
there was one in 1979 the u.s. command
center at NORAD got information that
there was a large-scale incoming Soviet
attack the the bomber crews got ready to
take off the airborne command center did
take off supposed to contain the include
the president but President Carter was
not on that airplane
so had things gotten farther the
president would not have been in the
loop on this unfortunately several
minutes down the line US satellite
sensors did not detect a Soviet
attack so they concluded they stood down
they concluded that there was something
wrong it was a false alarm it turned out
that a technician has mistakenly
inserted a training tape into the
computer system so in fact the attack
they were seeing looked just like the
one they were expecting because it was
the one they had trained with in 1983
Russian satellites detected five us
actually Soviet satellites detected five
incoming missiles and the person charged
that in charge that day had only a few
minutes to decide whether or not to send
it up the chain of command
the satellites appeared to be working
and yet he felt there was something not
quite right and he decided before he
knew he decided to tell his superior
that it was a false alarm
the person who made this decision people
have referred to him as the man who
saved the world stand aloft Petrov and
there was actually a movie about this
incident and about him by the same name
the man who saved the world it turned
out that what the satellites had seen
was not a launch of u.s. missiles but
Sun glint off clouds there was another
incident in 1995 where Russian radars
detected the launch of a missile off the
coast of Norway and it looked like it
could be the launch of a u.s. submarine
based nuclear missile and again things
went up the chain of command it got all
the way up to Yeltsin who also has a
nuclear football and they decided partly
because there were no corroborating
information from satellites that this
was also a false alarm it turned out
that it was a rocket launched by Norway
it was a scientific rocket
and Norway had informed other countries
as protocol to let other countries know
when you're doing this but it hadn't
reached the right person in Russia so
they when they saw this launch they
assumed the worst and went you know up
the chain of command so these are these
are just some examples and you can
imagine other things going wrong in in
similar ways former Secretary of State
of Defense rather
bill Perry who's with us today will be
speaking with us today in his recent
book my journey at the nuclear brink has
a very apt summary of this situation
these stories of false alarms have
focused a searing awareness of the
immense peril we face when in mere
minutes our leaders must make
life-and-death decisions affecting the
whole planet we don't want to be in this
situation and as bad as this is it
actually could get worse China's
military is interested in putting
China's missiles on hair-trigger alert
currently they are not they're not on
alert at all there is a concern among
China's military that their land-based
missiles are vulnerable they're mobile
but they're concerned that they're
vulnerable to being tracked by the
United States there is a an effort on
the part of the military to make this
policy change it's not clear how well
the high political leadership in China
is following what's going on this is
some recent information that we have
uncovered it's on our website and so
that would that would only be worse the
possibility of these false alarms would
be quite high for a new warning system
China would have to build a warning
system it doesn't have one and so
currently it's only the US and Russia
have this policy of being able to launch
under warning and so China might be a
third such country so our president
knows that this is a problem after he
was elected before he took office there
was a his his team put out a statement
Barack Obama believes that we should
take our nuclear weapons off
hair-trigger alert maintaining this Cold
War stance today is unnecessary and
increases the risk of an accidental or
unauthorized nuclear launch when his
administration did their Nuclear Posture
review in 2010 they decided not to
change this but it's not too late the
the odds are I don't want to mislead you
the odds are very low that he would make
a decision to take our missiles off
alert he could do so without
congressional approval without Russian
cooperation the most likely time that he
would do so I think is after the
election after the presidential election
but before he leaves office but if not
this president may be the next one it's
something that we're going to keep keep
pushing on and with that I will end
there is more information on this issue
on our website which is right here